[Aplausos]
[Música]
una vez uno Deja atrás los gritos de una
multitud frenética lo que llama la
atención al entrar en la enorme carpa en
la que dior presenta su colección de
poeta postes para el verano de 2023 no
son las personalidades provenientes
principalmente de Asia sino la
decoración una cueva diseñada por la
artista hecha de cartón reciclado es un
material que está en nuestra cabeza
banal extremadamente común a veces un
producto de desecho Y entonces es un
poco como una caja es como dice el
filósofo Emmanuel cossia la casa de las
cosas es cierto que gracias al cartón
conseguimos muchas cosas para viendo
para mal Epic game también me gusta la
idea de trabajar con un material frágil
como si fuera el material más precario
del mundo
[Música]
y a través del cuidado y el tiempo para
darle una visión que confunde El
material
es decir al mismo tiempo lo reconocemos
y al mismo tiempo se transforma
completamente
así que de hecho es un material un poco
pobre que a veces nos permite sustituir
las carencias Cuando no tenemos los
medios para utilizar mármol o bronce o
todo eso
era un torbellino Barroco María gracia
kiuri y rinde homenaje a la reina negra
italiana una de las primeras mujeres en
gobernar Francia madre de 10 hijos
permaneció viuda durante 30 años
Catalina de
medicinal
esta historia me apasionó porque quería
celebrar todo lo que Francia e Italia
tienen en común
Catalina de medici fue la primera en
comprender el poder de la moda ha
utilizado esto para definir sus propias
reglas decidió vestirse de negro como
expresión de la realeza
me ha gustado mucho reflexionar sobre el
hecho de que en el pasado de la moda
estaba cerca de la idea de poder
y es extraño Porque para mí la moda
siempre ha representado la libertad más
que el poder pero creo que era
importante pensar en ello
Cómo se traduce esto en la ropa una
recreación de la construcción de la
prenda algunas transformadas en encajes
adornados con bordados en 3D y un uso
desviado del corsé que llevaba Catalina
de medicine
[Música]
también creó el corsé pero el corsé que
hice es realmente un accesorio que
puedes usar de diferentes maneras
no es un corpiño restrictivo
es como un accesorio
ante tanta energía el público
difícilmente puede ocultar su emoción
me conmocionó era una vista tan hermosa
fue un honor para mí asistir fue
emocionante y ahora me siento bien
si Francia desplaza a Corea del Sur lo
mismo ocurre a la inversa ex bailarín de
ballet la joven mente creativa Víctor
weinsanto ha diseñado una línea de ropa
para los avatares del grupo de k-pop
Lite zoom
[Música]
me encanta el k-pop estoy muy contento
con este proyecto con el grupo Lite zoom
está ahí abajo es una oportunidad para
mí haber podido diseñar en el metaverso
Fue una gran colaboración y estoy feliz
de ir a verla con todo el mundo
espíritu colectivo Víctor winsanto acoge
en su espectáculo entre otros a sus
amigos diseñadores vestidos con sus
propias creaciones Charles de Big mogan
logentan y Kevin el Dúo a la cabeza del
sello Eagle Love la artista Micaela
stark banzan Rusia
Es realmente manifiesto para expresar
que todos somos compañeros que todos
hacemos el mismo trabajo pero que lo
hacemos de forma diferente creo que
todos nos inspiramos en los demás y ni
siquiera es un espectáculo sino un gran
campamento de vacaciones de hecho era un
amor común de ahí el casting de hecho
muchos creadores artistas que mostramos
una nueva generación
que ya no están del lado de poner
obstáculos en las ruedas para hacer
estrellas
como los años 90 era muy así
mientras que ahora se trata mucho más de
compartir me parece una idea
descabellada dije pero adelante cariño
porque ya sabes tengo mi desfile mañana
en realidad no debería estar aquí pero
estoy aquí por mi amigo
Y entonces mañana el desfile
Ah es el encuentro de Marilyn Monroe
Hola
como antídoto a la agresión actual la
guerra en Ucrania el calentamiento
global la inflación los escándalos las
noticias falsas
Por supuesto porque con todo lo que está
pasando ahora Necesitamos estar juntos
más que separados claramente
esto es bastante lógico de hecho
la industria de lujo va muy bien hoy en
día
la nueva Guardia está en efervescencia
Así que podemos decir sin dudarlo hasta
ahora todo va bien
[Música]